Film Courage: Does the antagonist have to
be the strongest character in a movie?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: Hhmm?
Well that…ohhh?
Strongest versus not strongest?
I would say they need to be at least as well-defined
as your hero.
I think they need to be one of the strongest
if not the strongest.
Like the hero and the antagonist probably
I would say neck and neck as far as well-defined.
Like oftentimes the antagonist is not well-defined
it’s just a villain.
I’ve heard it described as (bad villains)
as Muahaha.
It’s just that they are just evil for the
sake of being evil and that is the most uninteresting
villain you could create, it’s the bad guy
doing evil, laughing as he beats up somebody.
C’mon?
What’s more terrifying is…this may be
a terrible example but in the FORCE AWAKENS
you’ve got Kylo Ren the son of Han Solo
right?
He’s essentially sort of a villain, probably
an anti-hero/villain.
He’s a complicated character but to me I
found him really terrifying because he’s
like a child with a lot of power.
That to me is scary.
He wants to be loved, no one has loved him
before.
That’s the impression I got of him as a
character but boy he can stop a bullet and
it really makes you afraid of him because
he is so well-developed.
I think everyone can identify with that sense
of wanting to be loved.
I think we’ve all been in the presence with
someone with a lot of power and you don’t
know if they are going to snap at you and
do something dangerous like that.
Man…that is way more interesting than someone
who is just evil for the sake of being evil.
The perfect example is the guy, his rival
in the movie.
Brandon’s son, the redheaded guy who plays,
he the same age.
I’m blanking on the name…Gleeson [General
Hux, played by Domhnall Gleeson]!
He is a little bit more like evil for the
sake of being evil.
He doesn’t really have the backstory Kylo
Ren so it makes Kylo Ren way more memorable
in that film.
Film Courage: You’ve talked about backstory
and The Wound and you’ve compared several
films and said that all of them were orphans?
Jason: Yes, Batman, Spiderman, Harry Potter,
James Bond, Luke Skywalker.
The fact that those are all orphans is not
an accident.
That is on purpose.
That’s because the idea of not having parents
is like…we can all identify with what that
might be like.
Giving your hero a wound, that’s another
way to get us to care about them.
Orphan is one way but look at Jason Bourne.
His wound is amnesia.
That makes you really go “Man, that’s
a bummer!”
You make them great at what they do and some
sort of wound that they are dealing with is
too powerful a narrative things to do.
Film Courage: And Matt Damon in GOOD WILL
HUNTING he did not have parents either.
Jason: That’s right, another orphan and
his wound is from the foster care system.
His wound is this mental anguish that he carries.
You want him to learn to love so bad in that
movie.
It’s such a brilliantly written film.
A well-done character.